we do a week shows at comic-con down at
San Diego it's always a lot of fun and
you had this great moment were you and
Norman Reedus both did a surprise
walk-on on our show the audience went
insane but one of the most interesting
parts was we always send a car to go get
our guests bring them there we sent a
car to get you and Norman to take you to
the theater where we were shooting the
televised show and you guys said no
we're good we have motorcycles yeah
that's right yeah yes it's insane cuz at
comic-con fans are roaming the streets
like zombies and they are they go nuts
if they see someone from a TV show like
yours so what was that like
you know we had our helmets on so nobody
knew until we well your helmet says I am
Jeffery yeah it was a lot of fun we had
just gotten there and it's we just any
excuse to be able to get on a motorcycle
is right it was great for us and San
Diego is obviously very beautiful and a
wonderful day so why not get on a bike
but the problem was we followed the car
to where you were shooting because we
didn't know where we were going right
and with it the one thing that we do is
we write directions on our arms all the
time
whenever we're on bike rides but you
write the directions on your arm yeah so
you take a ride way to die real fast
well no you're careful about so we
followed the car but he went through the
wrong he would like at the front of the
studio where there was like a million
people right and you know we flip up the
visors and that was it and we got kind
of jumping us around yeah yeah yeah
which was awesome because you know the
whole thing about comic-con is you get
to spend time with fans I mean you get
to have that interaction that face time
with fans and we've had the last couple
years haven't been able to have that
time they're very careful at comic-con
the fans are in there nice yes but
incredibly enthusiastic very posh the
walking-dead probably the biggest show
at comic-con so when they see talent
they they get intense they have they're
very careful at comic-con to lock it
down like they have a lot of security or
law yeah yeah very if they used to put
us on the floor and we would get to meet
people and sign autographs for like an
hour but a couple years ago we were
doing it and you know people fifty feet
away started throwing their phones at us
so we would take a picture of ourselves
and throw it back but when there's 20
phones being thrown at you so like we
were getting like smacked yeah it's the
dumbest thing I think I've ever heard
sign my toaster oven that's exactly
right
each of those selfies is so unique so so
they took us off the floor and so now we
don't have that face-to-face time so
that day by pulling on into the front of
the studio was awesome I was a the floor
on comic-con a couple years ago I went
on the floor and I loved to just say hi
to people and I'm I don't mind at all
people coming up and and they suddenly I
wasn't that I didn't ask for it but they
had six giant guys in dark suits around
me and literally small like little
people were coming up to me like young
kids stuff dressed as Princess Leia
they're like could you have you were
like Conan's an [ __ ] and then they're
not wrong but they're you yeah and the
thing is with the security draws more
attention yeah then you can just walk in
you know what I mean like eight guys
there are seven feet tall four hundred
pounds each I think that's a little
overboard we're cool I can handle it